[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory and I hope you're
ready because in honor of Halloween it's
time we had once more into the twisted
mind of salad fingers last episode we
established that salad fingers has set
in the UK during the year 1939 trapped
in his own mind and forced to relive
various memories from World War one we
also saw the recurring theme of salad
fingers feeling trapped by and
abandoning babies and how it's fractured
mind constantly hops between different
personalities but what does it all need
how do these individual pieces add up to
one overall narrative and what the heck
does the ending mean you've had to wait
long enough so let's not waste any more
time let's get right into it when
looking at the ten episodes of salad
fingers there's a definite shift midway
through the series the first five
episodes are filled with bizarre moments
unexplained events strange characters
and veiled plot lines but it's in
episode 6 present that things start to
feel weightier
much more intentional it's this episode
that makes it clear that the random
disturbing moments sprinkled through the
series aren't just there for shock value
but rather possess a deeper meaning
crucial to unraveling the plot of it all
the episode revolves around the first of
the finger puppets Jeremy Fisher giving
the titular present of a horse
- salad fingers a gift that seems
completely arbitrary until we see old
horace horsecollar again in one of the
final and most gruesome moments from the
series episode tens visit to dr. papinek
where the doctor is launched through the
air and latches onto the side of the
horse tearing into his stomach as an
animal lover
it's brutal watching before stares of
salad fingers right so clearly these
moments are highly symbolic but symbolic
of what exactly
well let's hop back into episode 6 to
figure it out Jeremy Fisher appears and
salad greets him by saying
Jeremy fish it
I thought you were out fighting the
great wah so apparently it's a surprise
to see that jeremy has returned home
from the war so early but this is a line
that takes on a whole new tone just a
few minutes later when in the same
episode salad repeats it again can it be
fishing I thought you were fighting the
great Wow things have gotten serious in
a hurry but why is salad fingers
suddenly so aggressive towards Jeremy to
truly understand that we need to first
piece together their conversation and
piece together is an accurate
description because believe it or not
the conversation happens in two chunks
separated out and removed from one
another one side of the conversation
happens when salad is out playing with
horace horsecollar at the local toilets
and the second half is in the house
directed at the finger puppets what
seems like two fragmented streams of
thoughts when spliced together actually
gives us one completed conversation
between Jeremy and an angry father both
played by salad fingers fractured mind
here it is properly laid out
me fishing I thought you were out
sighting the Great Wall I'd like a word
with you and I won four accusations but
this one's cast-iron what is this
I've seen you tailgating my daughter
with aspirations of deflowering her rose
this isn't true you've got the wrong
bloke Squire I don't make mistakes
comrade this one's textbook flash the
salad fingers eating a version of
himself and you're left with
crystal-clear storytelling ladies and
gentlemen I don't know about you but it
makes so much more sense now write what
we see in this pivotal moment from the
series is the father figure actively
threatening a former soldier Jeremy for
trying to seduce and deflower his
daughter to flower you know take a roll
in the hay with her create the beast
with two backs break out the old
horizontal mambo all right enough of
Rosie ol hot dog I'm done now remember
this is salad rehashing past memories so
the fact that he eats his puppet in the
end or cannibalizes the head of some
other salad fingers seems to indicate
that this conversation didn't quite end
all that well for Jeremy most likely
with the father killing him extreme
maybe but it seems like the father's
fears about Jeremy might have been
well-founded you see think for a minute
about the horse Jeremy gives two salad
and then remember the fact that it
appears again in a doctor's office to
have its stomach ripped out knowing what
we know about the accusations against
Jeremy let's say for a second that he is
indeed trying to deflower this young
girl and what's more that he succeeds in
doing so under this context jeremy
giving salad fingers the present of a
horse is symbolic of him getting the
girl pregnant likewise that means she
would need to go see a doctor to have
things taken care of
Fiat giving birth or on the flip side
having the baby aborted and that's the
memory we see salad relive in episode 10
as at the doctor's office salad once
again flips through a couple
personalities where he starts as the
girl getting examined by the doctor ice
you'll be checking me Nimbus the camel
spots a girl who really enjoys her
examination a whole lot before snapping
into a new persona this time that of the
mother encouraging her daughter while
the baby is being born I know it hurts
just try and sit still the doctor ah the
miracle of childbirth at the hands of
the Swiss Army knife doctor and for as
gruesome as this scene is we can
confidently say that she gives birth
since the title of this episode is
birthday so we're now left with a
million-dollar question whose birthday
is it why it's none other than our good
friend the second and most crucial
finger puppet Hubert Kummer nail there
are actually plenty of hints to confirm
this sprinkled throughout the videos not
only does salad fingers tell us at the
beginning of episode 10 that it is
Hubert's birthday today Campins birthday
but also in a very short scene after the
doctor's visit we see the important
visual of Hubert being abandoned on the
ground surrounded by branches now as I
covered last episode baby imagery is
everywhere in this series especially
babies being abandoned with mr. branches
from episode 9 being one of the
strongest examples so to depict Hubert
lying there amongst a bunch of broken
branches all well a tree has somehow
grown between salad fingers legs is an
important visual symbol Hubert is
clearly the baby but there are other
hands sprinkled throughout the series as
well for instance in episode 8 salad
adopting the voice of a scolding parent
Hicks Hubert off the bed into a tray of
mock saying scrap that method once you
become Bedell dirty immigrants in my
house
it's not just an insult it's pointing to
the fact that Hubert was born of a black
father Jeremy Fisher which during the
World War one arrow was a big deal this
was the time in history when immigration
into the UK was on the rise due to the
war as a result what's known as
scientific racism flourished a time in
which white Europeans used false
scientific claims to prove that they
were the superior race things like
saying that the Caucasian brain was
anatomically larger than other races or
relating facial structure to overall
intelligence that coupled with the
increased immigration caused by the war
resulted in attitudes like the one salad
fingers expresses in this moment it's a
key point of seeing Hubert ostracized by
his own family because of his parentage
it's even reflected in the way Hubert
tastes in Episode two we see that Hubert
and you taste like Sutton pan again
indicating a different status than
someone like Marjorie who tastes like
sunshine does Hubert is simply
considered dirty or how does this all
fit with the ending as a refresher salad
fingers encounters a table with five
other salad finger looking creatures
except each is physically mutilated in
some way at the head of the table as a
sixth chair empty and presumably for him
salad is visibly uncomfortable at first
until the mysterious pole lowers down
with a gift a hat made out of the
remains of the now dead Milford cubicle
the president makes him feel at home and
the series ends with him saying in
triumph
from here to the grave what a truly
special day so WTF seriously we just saw
a horse get ripped apart and now this is
our big ending well yes actually and
here's why
salad fingers is Hubert cumber Dale the
child born out of wedlock that never
found his place always being ostracized
by a family that never wanted him in the
first place and this ending shows that
he finally feels as though he's found
acceptance a place where he fits in he's
found his family granted it's a family
of deformed mutants who don't actually
acknowledge his existence but hey it's
enough for him and Who am I to take that
away from our little green hero so first
how do we know that Hubert and salad
fingers are one in the same well it's
worth noting that after the doctor scene
in the forest Hubert as we discussed
gets left behind
suddenly when salad fingers his back of
the house the birthday party is no
longer for Hubert it's for him he's the
one the presents are for and he's also
the one excited about how the other
guest has remembered him on his big day
ma I thought you'd gotten it's also
worth noting that randomly Hubert is
wearing a top hat in this episode and
what gift does Sally get at the very end
of the video a similar-looking top hat
but it goes beyond that the Hubert
puppet is also the only one to be able
to change forms becoming black goo that
burns to the touch unlike the other
finger puppets this one is supernatural
a construct of salad fingers mind unlike
the other characters which are more
grounded in reality Hubert has also seen
the most and is one that we see in life
size scale multiple times even sharing
salads own memories but despite all of
this he also tends to only interact with
salad fingers it's true personality none
of the other characters that salad
fingers hops between both Margery and
Jeremy interact with other personalities
the angry father the disappointed
husband but Hubert seems mostly
connected to the true salad
fingers so if that's all the case that
it makes sense why this ending is so
moving four fingers in episode 8 we see
just how lonely needed so much so that
he keeps a memorial of hairs 5 different
pairs each one a different shade and
color he look so beautiful together
okay look quintet their mementos of his
lost family at the end of the episode
he's forced to get rid of them something
that is so devastating that he ends the
episode by crying in the corner of his
safety cover so we have five hairs but
also five different people at that final
table coincidence I think not in the end
I have no solid proof but I can only
assume that this scene is meant to be
salad fingers being reunited with the
five people in his life who have
abandoned him in some way people who've
either died or disowned him scenes that
we've witnessed across the series some
combination of the father figure we saw
in episode 4 who fled to France afraid
of being caged by a baby
Kenneth his younger brother from shore
leave who either died young or during
the Great War and he Bainbridge proudly
represented by the grey hair and the
most likely candidate for the voice of
Roger the radio a woman cold and
unforgiving to salad fingers as he was
growing up
Marjorie Stewart Baxter salads white
from episode 9 the wife who left him to
care for their baby alone and then a
Vaughn the baby he just didn't know how
to handle and had to give away maybe
even his mother who it's the episode 10
doctor's appointment as any indication
potentially died in childbirth five
hairs and five lost loved ones run away
dead were disappointed leaving salad
fingers should I say Hubert alone in his
made-up reality stuck in time and
trapped in his own unforgiving wasteland
that's why the final moment is so
important the platoon is all there and
the gift he's given is a hats a friend
hats like the one he gave to Hubert back
in M
five he's finally accepted he's found
his place at the table it's as though
salad fingers has finally come to grips
with who he is leaving the puppet behind
in the woods and being born again into
his true role as Hubert's so the episode
titled birthday actually has a double
meaning green monsters deserve some love
to a truly special day
[Music]
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts oh and full disclosure I
still have no idea what's the deal with
Milford cubicle or why it's his skin
making the friend hat maybe it's just a
remnant of the real world poking in I
don't know I'm a theorist I'm not a
miracle worker